what is my worst video Oh all of them
thank you shut up shut the [ __ ] up how
dare you it's more like a common
knowledge that I made a lot of garbage
as videos but you still do shut up what
did I say when did you all become so
sassy every [ __ ] time the comments
are so sassy can I make self-deprecating
jokes without everyone at good joining
it's too much man my worst videos let's
talk about that well I think this might
be a runner up guys I feel that already
hey what's the video that should not
whatsoever I have 35 million views oh
yeah that's flappy bird this is supposed
to be a three free games with parents so
I started playing dumb ways to die being
the greedy Swede that I am I changed the
title to flappy birds and bam you got
for 32 million views let's watch [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you you know what this actually
isn't that bad painfully unfunny oh
absolutely but it's not that bad come on
shut up okay you can stop with the
snarky comments already I know what
you're doing 34 millions you wrote
suggested it I google it people said
it's weird I'm I'm all for weird let's
do it you're talking to a [ __ ]
literally that's it right never done
that before oh wait I have oh no I
missed this PewDiePie I really don't I
really don't it's it's trying way too
hard just trying way too hard I think
that's the problem me my old videos and
I think that's why I dislike them so
much even though they might not be that
bad
how's it going my name is how's it going
bros my name is beer stop please please
stop you don't act like that's not you
and welcome to everyone loves these
videos see I miss this content I miss
this beautify you're funnier than you
are now I think the thing is that I have
a lot of younger audience and I think my
humor got drier and they don't get it
and I think that's fine I'm just doing
what I enjoy spending on stop for a
minute what a minute are you serious I'm
already this appeals to kids I totally
see that I'm Way more mature now
this video get so many dislikes but I
think it's funny okay I think I think
people didn't like the part where I
drank my own piss I think this might be
why so many people just liked it
and I would just like to say I saw a
good mythical morning they drank their
own piss and they were fine with it so I
thought if I drink my own piss it won't
be that bad it was really [ __ ] bad
and I would never do it again and I
wouldn't recommend it cuz it doesn't say
it tastes like piss by the way that's
what it tastes like I got a lot of
questions
it tastes like piss alright we're back
in this vagina hole full of hair oh it's
the worst video on my channel I die
shame every time I see it because I
accidentally uploaded a video with just
my face cam I had edited the whole thing
me and Mark said we're going out to the
cinema and I upload this [ __ ] video
instead without looking I come back from
the cinema I see this I panic I realized
my YouTube is over what the [ __ ] have I
done I got stuck at apart and I keep
licking my moustache I didn't even know
I did that so if you think my old videos
were bad well there you go
I still make shitty content guys I still
manage to [ __ ] up somehow recently I did
the fast video where I made fun of naff
and markiplier
I think it was funny people hated that I
made fun of that like they absolutely
hated it and then the fact that I wasn't
taking the game seriously when what's
there to take seriously it's a [ __ ]
it's the fifth game it's the fifth one
guys how many do you need
it was 18 jump scares in this video or
you think I'm seriously gonna get scared
of that the thing is that people got
pissed because I was giving an honest
feedback on the game but really people
wanted me to just play it and fake being
scared I realized that there's no way
for me to win by making an app video I'm
just gonna get [ __ ] regardless because
people want me to get scared people
wanted to see a reaction on me there's
no way in hell I could get scared while
playing these games because it's
[ __ ] like that it's the same
jump-scare over and over if someone goes
in yell yelling at you like boo you
might be like I'll [ __ ] if someone goes
to yells at you boo five thousand
[ __ ] times you're gonna want to kill
that person that's enough for you I
don't get it but hey that's alright we
can bear simulator so when a game I got
so much [ __ ] for this video
oh boy hoody pie is an [ __ ] this is
why I dislike PewDiePie because he says
a game that is awesome and hard to make
a piece of [ __ ] if there's any piece of
[ __ ] it's beautiful and there's all
these Russian people saying something I
don't know what they want funny that
markiplier played the game yet made
better content than pewdiepie then again
when has PewDiePie made good content
because of you the developer the develop
or won't update this game anymore and
there is more in the game than you
showed us I am so disappointed in you
basically I gave a very honest review of
this game because it was trying to live
off the mean you know the goat simulator
mean and I had higher expectations that
it would actually be funny when really
it was an broken boring as hell mess and
I realized while making the video
there's no way in hell I can make this I
can honestly like pretend that this is a
funny game to play
I gave some honest feedback and made fun
with it and then the developer said Oh
everyone hates my game I'm so sad I'm so
sad now and it's like okay well sorry
you'd made a bad game but then people
saw that he said that they're like oh
you made him quit being a developer
pewdiepie it's your fault for ruining in
a man's life you're an [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all I
did was play the game and I didn't like
it I'm sorry
I thought you wanted me to be honest
people on the internet don't want
honesty finesse and bear simulator I'm
just not gonna play okay there's no way
to win it you think I never got in
criticism you think if I just quit and
blamed it on someone else it would be
their fault if I [ __ ] up no that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I've done so
many [ __ ] were used here I'm on
today's show already I hate these people
because they said that your kids have
not only kids watch PewDiePie thank you
very much okay I'm sure there are some
teenagers as well I was five years ago
and are you making a good living this
way it's amazing like my job is to play
video games it's a job that all the
parents way to avoid the question there
pits I I always get the question how
much money do you make that's all that
matters right that's all you care about
that's the only thing we can understand
so tell us please how much money do you
make us really nothing else that you
have ever done well ever we will ever
give a [ __ ] about to me you see so many
[ __ ] youtubers font with their fancy
car or their house or their gear or
whatever to me that just shows that they
are so insecure about what they made on
YouTube that they have to somehow show
people that in a way that they other
people will understand what it is
they've done well my channel is pretty
[ __ ] but I got a sweet-ass Ferrari I did
something no you uploaded a bunch of
click Biddy videos on the Internet
that's what you did good content
it's irrelevant on YouTube let's let's
get real here let's look at what I've
made all this stuff now you do come on I
really do wish I could understand I said
do they advertise on there how do you
make any money how do you make any money
how do you do it how do you make any
money
how ads just like television I think I
said it even inside it's pretty simple
yeah
pretty simple yeah hence good job good
job February 2 P 2 pie that was good I'm
glad glad you stood up for yourself so a
lot of you may have not seen this one
but it's the first episode of scared
beautifies and it's very different from
all the other episodes because I didn't
actually know we were filming it I have
no [ __ ] clue and I never felt more
uncomfortable in my entire life because
I felt like I was put on the spot out of
nowhere I thought I was getting a
physical for the show and they really
did a good job tricking me I feel like
I'm pretty hard to fool but they really
got me on this one and I'm just annoyed
the whole time I'm just like pissed off
I'm just like what the [ __ ] is dead oh
yeah so this girl Nikki that was
supposed to be my personal assistant
throughout the show I never felt more
uncomfortable in my entire life because
she was flirting with me 100% and I
didn't hit me she had been flirting with
me throughout the whole day it was all
part of the show like she was an actress
at this point I was in this chair and
she was 100% clearly hitting on me I
just wanted to get out of that situation
what look at things gonna be no one
liked everything I didn't and I know
this was filmed the event I like that
man you good look I'm just ignoring
their hoping she would stop oh yeah my
heart would sum definitely raising she
was writing a heart on the thing I was
just like me was the best hair ever no
don't no don't [ __ ] I wish it came
across vadik it's like I was dying I
asked you bros on Twitter to link me my
worst video and literally all of you are
just linking my [ __ ] channel thinking
you're so [ __ ] funny
your whole channel all of them all of
them how can I send you all of your
videos I can't send them all can't send
all your videos I just send him his own
channel all of them I would post links
because there's Twitter limit sorry all
videos won't fit one vide all of them
all of them it's hard to choose oh all
right yes I made a lot of bad videos
many of them will I make more bad videos
in the future absolutely there's no
question about it I I like to try
different things sometimes it doesn't
work sometimes it does and I appreciate
that you who are subscribed to me give
me a chance and even if I'm one video
may not have been the best you still
stick around for another one and I think
that's pretty cool I appreciate that a
lot it that means a lot to me that I can
do different things but yeah thanks for
watching this video hopefully was in the
worst one remember there's anyone care
about likes does it do anything I don't
understand YouTube but as always see you
next Tuesday for more videos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]